life I keep wanting to come back to that
statement and I've seen you put that in
different things look like an
explanation point and I realized that
it's more than just a word I think it
embodies your mission statement for your
journey and it sounds like that you have
seen things that are sad but that you
bring with it the realization maybe that
we're not going to be around forever and
you want to take advantage of the time
that you have and so why is life so
precious and how do you apply that every
day to what you do if we were not alive
we wouldn't be here you and me talking
so this is a precious moment for me you
know life is the greatest gift of this
universe especially human life because
when you when you look in the universe
and you see all other creation we are
the ones who have this ability to reason
we are the ones who I am sure the other
species and other creatures beautiful
creatures of this planet also have
emotions but who is the one who has the
ability to express everything humans and
so to be born human itself is one of the
biggest gifts in my opinion it it also
involves tremendous suffering but you
know when you look at it as a whole
would I rather have been born then not
one as me this entity yes I want to be
born I want to experience all that there
is to experience I want to fight through
this journey I have this optimism that I
came here as this person for a reason
onto this planet whether there is
something beyond or not that is a whole
different discussion but I like to
believe that this this instinct what I
have this reason I came on this planet
there is a purpose I want to find that
purpose every single day I want to find
that purpose and the more I grow the
more I mature I'm
realizing that my purpose is humanity
for me I I love people I love to connect
with people in whatever positive way
possible you know so this gift of me
becoming a physician happened almost as
its own journey without me being aware
of the journey because very early in
life I at the age of 17 I went into
medical school in India we all do you
know we go straight out of high school
pre university medical school so that
was almost something that just happened
as its own journey and when I look back
to me it is like every moment of my
journey has been almost engineered by a
universal power and you know at what
points this instinct for me to do film
at what points my film became a success
at what point my acting's my song became
a success at what point i developed a
fan following all these things when you
look back there all magical and yes
there are low points also i mean and i
am the eternal optimist i do not believe
in discussing my huge problems or small
problems to everybody there is no need
for me to do that because i don't expect
everybody to solve my problems so i
would rather in my capacity when I when
I have a platform I would rather take
the positive route I would rather see
how can I impact this person's feeling
and make it better at this moment if
it's in film it's through my creativity
if it's in medicine it's one-on-one you
know I am sitting with each patient you
know in film you have that larger scale
but is of course it's a completely
different way or I mean this this takes
yours of study practice at that's a
whole different thing but that is my
approach to it you know so so yes I mean
coming back to that point life you know
I when you see the fragility of it every
day in front of you that's when you
realize how precious it is that's when I
realize when people take it for granted
you know when they take
their privileges for granted wherever it
may be in the Western world many
children many teenagers take the
privileges for granted that's when I
always want to show them stories and you
know because all of them don't have that
the not the resources but they don't
have those opportunities of seeing the
difficulties everywhere else in the
world you know and when I see that
variety of life and humanity I am like
in my tiny little capacity as long as I
live as long as I am able to have these
interactive platforms I will spread
positivity because what is the other
option I can be negative right what is
that what is that solving what is that
doing at least by being positive and
putting a smile on somebody's face I am
bringing more awareness to tour to human
conditions that are existent you know
and I'm trying to in that one moment
uplift one little something in
somebody's life so that is my approach
to life and but i do know life can be
very beautiful you know i have been very
blessed in many many ways with a
wonderful strong family background i
have seen what family can mean you know
if you really put the effort you put
commitment you put sincerity you you put
sacrifices and you allow long-term
things to happen allow long-term
relationships to flourish the benefits
are creating a legacy which which lifts
the level of humanity human quality by
better education creating people who are
more aware more instinctive more
comforting you know more compassionate
and for that you have to sacrifice and
you know you have to sacrifice for
example the the divorces that happen
everywhere you know I am NOT saying in
those divorces shouldn't happen I am
just saying look deeper into it I mean
is it really worth breaking human
relationships that easily you know is it
really worth it is it is it is it better
to create strength discipline
togetherness family
allow that to you know create a strong
background for children to grow up in
you know they're there are so many so
many things that encompassed life that I
can talk to you for hours one at a time
but we don't have the time yeah I would
wish to get more time I don't know if
that answers your question but us okay
thank you thank you yeah so yeah life to
me is a brilliant gift brilliant gift of
what I don't know if the universe
somewhere somewhere this human life
evolution this gift that has come about
if only all of us viewed it that way and
took all the trials and tribulations in
our stride and channeled a path strong
and fearless you know go forward live
your dreams don't be afraid everyone
makes mistakes but don't be afraid you
know so that is my way of looking at it
you